any questions before we move under 24
and i'll come back to 22 23 okay let's
go all the way to page what pages of
guys page 14 yep so there's only three
pages at the end there here we go a
family currently pays six hundred
dollars rent per week assuming a
constant inflation rate now when I
skimmed through as a class we did this
really well so thumbs up again you're
pretty much and the formula sheet tells
you this right sorry that yeah formula
datasheet you've got this form you can
pretty much just use right it was pretty
hard to get it wrong if you had that
form and then you went to your
calculator okay but people who've got
that wrong maybe they didn't know how
you use that form or they were solving
something else like writing 600 equals
like p times 1 point so there were
solving for something else as students
got a bit confused in that way okay a
principle of ten thousand dollars to be
invested for three years determine which
other following is the best investment
option and when I was looking at this
paper of myself I sort of went yes
because we've done like almost this
exact question just with slightly
different numbers so you can see there's
a couple of different ways to go through
this here's method one hears method to
but clearly you have to make the
comparison you got to try a try B and
then you absolutely absolutely needed to
have a conclusion okay um I was really
sad and how many people not just in our
class who looked at this and they did
all the calculations they need it but
they didn't actually answer the question
they just sort of put numbers there and
hope that they spoke themselves rather
than actually determining which one was
which okay all right ah next page uh mr.
Faircloth bought a lot of shares I you
can see there the 1000 shares times nine
dollars 80 that's the total value that
dividend yield right the four percent
that applies to an entire value right
you didn't have to do it in that order
you could say four percent of nine
dollars a t and x cows and you're going
to get the same thing
but again the better responses they said
okay like what are these two things and
they calculated them separately rather
just kind of mashing numbers together
and hoping that everything was okay all
right yes ok so the dividend is about
how much sir okay um I earn all of these
shares in the company and if I sell all
of them like i buy them in a certain
point of time and they increase in value
and then I sell all of them and
hopefully you know I've made a bit of a
profit okay but if I hold on to those
shares the Gunther look up with the
company wants to reward me for being
unfaithful investor so they're paying
out like every year or every quarter or
what it is this dividend which is some
some proportion of that so in this case
it was four percent because maybe the
company did pretty well that you focus
it's a lot question ah so I have all of
its to my question yep all that working
but accidentally put another line of
work anything because I put like what
did you put i put the 9800 um plus the
390 you as my final one yeah and you got
like what is that 10,000 something or
1019 to whatever extent you know what I
mean hold on oh is it right I searched
me says it your paper looks like kind of
like this like that like a yep shop ok
so this is a good question and this sort
of hopefully like even if this is not
gonna ticular area that you may this
will this company happen quite a lot ok
so what this is about and sometimes by
the way I will also point out not on
this question but on others you might
see this afternoon ok um there are lots
of acronyms you've seen CFM before which
is like you make an error early on and
you carry it forward through your hair
through your working this stands for
ignore subsequent error okay so what
this might mean is ok I do some like in
algebra okay i simplify down a
simplified down and then I get to the
Edsel and then I do something extra
which happens to be wrong okay but
depending on what you've done in the
question it's like all that earlier
stuff that's what we were looking for so
therefore we're just gonna quietly
ignore that
pretend you never wrote it so sometimes
it's happened and there's no penalty but
in this case now and I'm going to answer
what in this case it didn't happen
actually adding more information it did
mean like okay we work on a pay you the
mark with you one out of two one you can
tell you okay now here's why right again
we're trying to do our best to read your
mind through your wedding yeah that's
all we can do and the HSC you never even
get to have this conversation you just
get a number at the end and that's the
end of it that's an in the story so
we're trying to judge what do you
understand and what do you not
understand by what you've written okay
now what I'm about to say may or may not
be true but it's the best indication we
have as we look at your working when I
look at a student who's done this okay
what I surmise what I conclude is that
by writing this the student doesn't
actually know what the dividend that
gets paid is right like the dividend
that gets paid is the whole point is
that the person doesn't sell off all
their shares they still hold onto them
and then they get given this sort of
small part ok so to write this down kind
of indicates whether I do or not and we
just met as an honest accident that I
don't understand that the dividend only
represents the four percent and that's
what we were assessing that's what we
were looking for I could put down a
whole bunch of things that are right but
if I put this down it demonstrates that
don't it indicates it exhibits that I
don't understand the difference between
those ok if you want to take it to the
logical extreme suppose um suppose I
actually didn't know that the thievin
you knew that 392 was an important
number maybe I didn't know that right I
could just take um one two three numbers
and I could combine them in every
possible I could add them all together i
can multiply them i can add a multiplier
and i could write them all down right so
that this working is somewhere in my
working but there's all this wrong stuff
what does that indicate for you as a
marker about me if i put down all of
that they're just try yeah i'm just kind
of throwing stuff against the wall and
hoping something sticks I don't really
get it does that make sense
so that's why we're going to this
processor and learning I heard it's been
a long time but we need to review just
say that women before it's a forms a
good foundation okay okay so i'll try
that took a little more time than i
intended are almost finished so part two
one year after purchasing them then he
sells then he sells right he sells the
shares for that amount what's his total
profit if he's charged this brokerage
and that you can see the rule for
brokerage there was a huge range in when
I talk to people afters like how much
time to have that some people have heaps
of time and some people madly right into
the dying seconds okay I would probably
suggest being able to do it quickly and
people in the real I spoke to some of
you who were ever do it quickly
generally as you're going through there
are two things are doing number one
you're recognizing things quite quickly
oh I know this question and then you've
watched straight into you like it's the
difference between like whenever essays
in english i didn't i memorize know
where science right i know a lot of
people now like the majority people
maybe even memorize the SS so i'd have
to get in there and i've read the
question and then I think about it right
whereas if you've memorized something
you look at it and you think okay how am
I going to massage my thing to fit into
that and then and then you should start
rising on okay whereas every time I
finished a sentence I'm a no pic shall I
right now okay now clearly that's going
to soak up your time and the same thing
happens here if you look at a question
like this and being honest this is a
very very good example because it's hard
and you like River Ridge I've got to
read all of this stuff like and then try
and piece together my response to this
because I've never seen this kind of
thing before it's going to take me like
two three times longer to do a question
like that so that's the first thing the
second thing as well like if you got to
any part of the exam and you're like I
didn't even get to a tenth these then
really you should go through an exam and
from now on by the way all your exams in
the MPC will include
reading time okay they don't always in
the MP ones but from now on there will
you want to look through this and you
say I can nail am on a name too I'm very
confident and I can do those quickly
right as opposed to like everyone is
first but maybe that's a bit of a weak
spot for me and I know it's going to
kind of chew up my time so that's an
exam technique method right I would say
it's like some people do it in reverse I
prefer do the hard stuff us because they
can keep a really good water all the
time but I've never been very good at
there personally I always try and nail
down right I know these intersections
I'll be good at orono these are the
questions I can do you quickly and then
I come back all right now let's try and
piece this together yes okay so all
right why don't we and I what I'm going
to ask is since as a gray we did so
poorly maybe again if you've not done is
pick up your pen in your book and let's
try to follow this through from step one
from this part of the question okay so
i'll talk about this i'll talk about
this so let's start through one year
after purchasing them Wade sells the
shares for ten dollar 70 per share
what's his total profit if he's charged
brokerage as shown so one step at a time
this first line what could we write over
here I you know this is some questions
are better done than others what is that
first line actually representing yeah
very good value of all shares right
there's a thousand of them and they're
worth ten dollar seventy each so he
multiplies through and that's how he
gets this number so far so good now what
is this second line why is there a
subtraction happening what is the number
that's being subtracted where does it
come from
yeah it comes from part one right cuz
that ten thousand seven hundred dollars
part of that is money he spent right at
the beginning to get the shares in the
first place so he has to subtract those
so nine hundred dollars this is actually
the profit I suppose you could say like
gross profit because he sold it but he
hasn't actually the burka hasn't
actually charge any fee yet so that's
why I'm calling it gross okay so then it
says brokerage and then you have to look
which transaction category there's one
two three categories that he could fall
into right can you see why the arrow is
on the last one why is it that one yeah
ten thousand seven hundred dollars it
only can be this last category of over
10,000 does that make sense okay so
that's why he's identified that and
that's where that 0.01 which of course
represents what does it represent it
represents that one percent that we all
had it already had up there one percent
of that total transaction that's the
$107 that appears there right so you
really like a lot of people didn't get
that number it's because we didn't
recognize where to calculate like the
over ten thousand dollars what's over
ten thousand dollars so you had to get
this first and then you also had to know
what to multiply minor okay so
admittedly it was hard to get to that
mark question that part there what did
you get one out of two
again I think and I did mention this
before right so it could have been a
little bit clearer I live with that okay
but you know it does say it does say
right in the back this is exactly the
same kind of problem that we experienced
in the what is it Alex and Kim that
question there's a connection between
the parts and it's kind of implied to
use that I will point out if you had a
look at San hoc questions they'll often
make that more explicit which probably
you were expecting that means that
you'll be ready for it next time yep yep
correct correct okay and you can see
like oh these are the same guy like
that's what's happening here does that
make sense